Matt Gates has filed to remove Kevin
McCarthy as Speaker of the House oh boy
aren't we excited apparently Kevin
McCarthy cut a back room deal with
Democrats to get this continuing
resolution through and it's an insult to
everybody who believes that we should be
fixing the problems of of the corruption
in Congress and not just layering them
on but this is basically what's
happening Matt Gates is trying to get an
uh trying to make bring about an end of
the to the Omnibus spending bills where
they just put 5,000 Pages we're all
spending the money we're buying it all
vote Yes or don't he wants to bring on
single subject spending Kevin McCarthy
is basically playing games they're doing
what all members of Congress always do
where they basically say well we'll just
uh we'll keep funding it the way it is
and we'll we'll we'll deal with these
things later in response to Matt Gates
threatening to remove Kevin McCarthy as
Speaker of H of the house or to file
they're trying to remove Matt Gates so
it's getting uh uh pretty wild and um
well we'll see how this one plays out
Donald Trump was in court today for his
lawsuit he called The The J uh he called
the judge a rogue and we'll talk about
that apparently they've dropped some of
the claims against him